REPUBLICAN SENATE CANDIDATE DR.
MEHMET OZ PRESSED ABOUT  THE
SHARP, SOMETIMES MOCKING ATTACKS
HE AND HIS CAMPAIGN ARE MAKING
ABOUT DEMOCRAT JOHN FETTERMAN
AND FETTERMAN'S ABILITY TO
SERVE.
FETTERMAN, OF COURSE, RECOVERING
FROM A STROKE HE SUFFERED BACK
IN MAY.
HE HAS AUDITORY ISSUES AND SAYS
THE USE OF CLOSED CAPTIONING
HELPS BECAUSE HE SOMETIMES HAS
TROUBLE HEARING OR PROCESSING
SPOKEN WORDS.
THEY INCLUDE SUGGESTING
FETTERMAN MIGHT NOT HAVE
SUFFERED A STROKE IF HE ATE
VEGETABLES.
OZ SAID YESTERDAY HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE THERE IS CLOSED
CAPTIONING ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
TODAY, THOUGH, A DIFFERENT TONE
IN THIS SIT-DOWN WITH NBC.
>> WHY WOULD YOU ALLOW YOUR
CAMPAIGN TO MOCK HIM LIKE THAT.
>> I HAVE TREMENDOUS COMPASSION
FOR WHAT JOHN FETTERMAN IS GOING
THROUGH.
NOT ONLY DO I APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES BUT I KNOW HIS
SPECIFIC AILMENT BECAUSE IT IS A
SPECIALTY OF MINE.
I ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY AND
DEAL WITH ISSUES AS THEY COME UP
BUT HE HAS HIS OWN SET OF ISSUES
AND WE SHOULD HAVE HAD A DEBATE
ALREADY.
>> WOULD YOU EVER TALK TO YOUR
PATIENTS LIKE THIS GENTLEMAN.
>> NO.
>> INTERESTING IN THE SENSE I
WOULDN'T TALK TO MY PATIENTS
LIKE THAT.
ALSO INTERESTING IN THAT
CANDIDATES DO SOME THINGS IN
THEIR ADS AND RALLIES BEFORE
THEIR SUPPORTERS BUT PUT THEM IN
AN INTERVIEW AND TEND TO WANT TO
BE SOFTER.
>> AND LET THEIR CAMPAIGN
OPERATIVES GO FURTHER THAN WHAT
HE DID.
THE CAMPAIGN HAS MADE JOHN
FETTERMAN'S HEALTH AN ISSUE.
THEY HAVE GONE AFTER HIS ABILITY
TO, YOU KNOW, RESPOND AND COME
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND BE
ABLE TO GOVERN.
LOOK, IN FAIRNESS HIS HEALTH,
VOTERS SHOULD CONSIDER WHETHER
OR NOT THAT JOHN FETTERMAN IS
FIT TO SERVE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DOES THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE DEAL WITH
THAT?
AND I CAN TELL YOU TALKING TO
DEMOCRATS UP HERE, THEY ARE
STILL HOPEFUL, STILL CONFIDENT
THAT FETTERMAN CAN PULL IT OUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY BUT ARE
NERVOUS SOME OF THESE HEALTH
ISSUES COULD ULTIMATELY HURT HIS
ABILITY TO WIN THIS RACE.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE IN A
MUCH STRONGER POSITION IN THE
FINAL WEEKS OF THE CAMPAIGN BUT
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY CLOSE
RACE.
>> WHAT FETTERMAN HAS BEEN
TRYING TO DO SAY, THIS IS A
DISABILITY.
THIS IS A TEMPORARY DISABILITY
SO WHEN YOU HEAR THINGS LIKE THE
OZ CAMPAIGN SAYING, WELL, THEY
DON'T HAVE CLOSED CAPTIONING ON
THE SENATE FLOOR, THEY DIDN'T
HAVE WHEELCHAIR ACCESS EITHER.
SO THOSE --
>> LET ME JUMP IN.
IT WASN'T ALL THAT LONG AGO YOU
HAD TO GO A LONG DISTANCE TO
FIND A LADIES ROOM.
>> THERE ARE CURRENT SENATORS
THAT ARE SURVIVORS OF STROKE
CURRENTLY SITTING IN THE SENATE
SO IT'S NOT TO YOUR POINT IT'S
NOT OUT OF THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUFFERED, YOU
KNOW, STROKES AND OTHER
POTENTIAL DISABILITIES THAT THEN
GO ON TO SERVE THEIR COUNTRY
WHETHER IT'S IN THE SENATE OR IN
THE HOUSE.
>> PEOPLE DEALING WITH
CHALLENGE, MEDICAL CHALLENGES,
OTHER CHALLENGES SOMETIMES ARE
GOOD FOR A CONVERSATION BECAUSE
THEY HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND BUT
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT DEMOCRATS
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF JITTERS
HERE, FETTERMAN'S CAMPAIGN
HIMSELF CLEARLY SEES THIS AS AN
ISSUE BECAUSE YOU DON'T PUT
MONEY BEHIND SOMETHING UNLESS
IT'S AN ISSUE.
A BRAND-NEW TV AD OUT TODAY.
>> AFTER MY STROKE I WAS JUST
GRATEFUL TO SEE GISELE AND OUR
KIDS.
POLITICIANS SPEND SO MUCH TIME
FIGHTING ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
DON'T MATTER.
I'LL ALWAYS BE FOCUSED ON WHAT
DOES, ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE,
LOWER COSTS, GOOD JOBS.
MORE TIME WITH THOSE WE LOVE.
I'M JOHN FETTERMAN AND I APPROVE
THIS MESSAGE.
>> JUST PROOF RIGHT THERE, COSTS
MONEY TO PUT ADS ON TV IN
PHILADELPHIA BUT A LOT OF MEDIA
MARKETS FROM ACROSS SCRANTON,
WILKES-BARRE AND OUT TO
PITTSBURGH.
>> USUALLY WHEN YOU HAVE THE
DEBATE OVER THE DEBATE IT'S LIKE
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN ARIZONA,
YOU KNOW, ONE CAMPAIGN SENDING A
CHICKEN AFTER ANOTHER CANDIDATE
AND IT JUST BEING MORE ABOUT
BEING AFRAID TO CONFRONT ONE
ANOTHER ON THE ISSUES.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, IT'S, I
THINK, PROBABLY MORE OF A
NEGATIVE FOR FETTERMAN IN THE
EYES OF THE VIEWERS, THE VOTERS
RATHER BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE
WHETHER IT'S USING CLOSED
CAPTION OR SOME OTHER WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR HIS CURRENT
PHYSICAL STATE HE'S OKAY
COGNITIVELY.
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT HE'S MAKING.
HIS BRAIN IS WORKING, IT'S JUST
THE MOTOR SKILLS HE NEEDS TO GO
FROM HIS THOUGHT PROCESS TO HIS
MOUTH IS WHERE HE NEEDS EXTRA
HELP.
IF THEY CAN FIND A WAY TO DO IT,
PRESUMABLY IT WOULD HELP ASSUAGE
THE VOTERS' CONCERNS YOU'RE
HEARING FROM DEMOCRATS HERE.
>> YEAH, AND THE PART OF THE
THING HERE, YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS
OUT IN PENNSYLVANIA DURING THE
PRIMARY, THIS IS PRE-STROKE, SO
MUCH ABOUT JOHN FETTERMAN'S
PERSONA WAS THE WAY HE WAS ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH VOTERS, ABLE TO
TALK TO VOTERS, GO BACK AND
FORTH AND ENGAGE ON ANY NUMBER
OF ISSUES AND FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
THAT WAS HIS WAY OF CAMPAIGNING.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY MUCH DIFFERENT
NOW AND ONE REASON WHY NOT JUST
HIS HEALTH BUT NOT JUST DOING
THAT ON THE TRAIL.
THE RETAIL POLITICKING WHICH
COULD BE HURTFUL IN THE FINAL
WEEK.